bonsoir je veux juste dire un petit truc
voilà on me dit beaucoup c'est pas grave
de ne pas avoir le césar ce qui compte
c'est d'être nommé émincer pas vrai non
mais faut pas mentir aux jeunes c'est
horrible de pas l'avoir c'est atroce
hyper mignon tu arrives en limousine du
repart en bus non plus il ya un truc
c'est que c'est cruel parce que tu te
souviens pas de ce qu'ils ont pas un
alors que bon après tout je veux pas si
mal que ça non mais c'est vrai par
exemple l'année dernière meilleure
actrice vous souvenez qui étaient nommés
n'ont par contre vous souvenez très bien
qu'il a eue
bérénice bejo pardon bérénice béjo non
c'est moi qui aie non c'est bérénice
bejo dont dix artistes
mais non c'est dujardin dans the artist
non c'est bérénice bejo non l'année
dernière meilleure actrice
marina foïs dans polisse
ça peu embarrassant marina non mais
enfin je m'en souviens c'est ma vie
j'étais là j'étais assise à la place de
michel viard moz le chalet j'étais pas
vous l'avez enregistré la cérémonie donc
je serai bien repasser les images
ok très bien de votre volonté soit faite
des images un meilleur actrice 2012 et
le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à bérénice bejo dans dix
artistes situe à 12 me faire douter
bon alors